el mundo vive más problemas que la
guerra en ucrania el director general de
la organización mundial de la salud
alertó que se están olvidando otros
problemas que afectan a millones de
personas
'iron with the world really woods y cual
no sé si el mundo le da la misma
atención a las vidas blancas y negras lo
dije la semana pasada su black and white
lives and plant
necesito ser franco y honesto en cuanto
a que el mundo no está tratando la raza
humana de la misma manera algunos son
más iguales que otros sanz marc moore y
world canadairs
especialmente en oriente medio y en
áfrica donde también hay conflictos
bélicos internos como el de tigre en
etiopía es
decir
valeri transfor sus continuos el asedio
de las fuerzas etíopes y eritreos
continúa para evitar la calamidad
humanitaria y que mueran cientos de
miles de personas más necesitamos un
acceso humanitario sin restricciones de
quienes refuerzan el asedio from 2 ring
forcing decide la onu alertó también que
hay más de 15 millones de personas en
riesgo en el cuerno de áfrica la región
sufre la peor sequía en décadas un
problema que se agudiza sobre la salud
de los más pequeños
austin fotos puntos y esta sequía es la
peor que hemos visto en 20 años afectó a
toda la comunidad especialmente a los
niños sobre todo a los menores de 5 años
estamos recibiendo muchos niños
desnutridos roser soláns la organización
internacional para las migraciones
específicos etiopía tiene 7 millones de
personas en riesgo y 1,4 millones de
cabezas de ganado muertas otros tantos
en somalia en donde no se veía una
sequía de este calibre desde hace 40
años